la figura be es una copia a escala de la
figura a lo que vamos a hacer es
averiguar cuál es el factor de escala
que se usó para dibujar la figura be a
partir de la figura a ausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la respuesta por su
cuenta lo que tenemos que hacer es ver
los lados correspondientes y pensar en
cuanto fueron escala 2 por ejemplo este
lado de la figura
corresponde a este lado de la figura ve
aquí este lado mide 2 unidades y en la
figura de este lado mide 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
unidades parece que este lado fue
escalado usando un factor de 3 por lo
que si la figura ve es una copia escala
de la figura a entonces todos sus lados
deben tener el mismo factor de escala
podemos verificar esto realizando la
longitud de todos sus grados pero no es
necesario ya que nos dicen que la figura
be es una copia a escala pero vamos a
revisar uno de los lados para verificar
que tienen la misma escala este lado
corresponde a este lado de acá en la
figura a este lado mide tres unidades y
antes de ver cuál es la longitud de este
lado en la figura vez vamos a
la longitud multiplicando por esto el
factor de escala de tres que es 9
así que este lado de acá debe medir 9
unidades de longitud vamos a ver si se
cumple 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9 con esto
podemos confiar en que la figura b es
una copia escala de la figura y que el
factor de escala es 3 con eso terminamos
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo